>>> I'M HERE REACTING TO THE
DONOVAN MITCHELL TRADE WHICH
ME OUT OF LEGITIMATELY
NOWHERE.
I WAS HA ASLEEP ON MY COUCH
ABOUT A HALF-HOUR AGO WHEN THE
TRADE NEWS BROKE.
WHENOU LOOK AT THE TWEET AT
THE TOP, IT DOESN'T SHOW THE
WHOLE THING.
I SAW DONOVANANITCHELL TRADE.
I THOUGHT IT WAS MORE TRADE
RUMORS LIKE WE'VE SEEN OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
BUT I INSTEAD HE'S HEADING TO T
CLEVELAND CAVALIERS.
WHAT WAS THE COMPLETE SHOCK TO
ME, WE HAD SEEN LIKE THE KNICKS
WERE THE MAIN TEAM, THE
CHARLOTTE HORNETS, THE
WASHINGTON WIZARDS HAD BEEN
MENTIONED HERE AND THERE BUT IT
SEEMED LIKE A CONCLUSION THAT HE
WOULD END UP AS A NEW YORK
KNICK.
I KNOW FANS WERE PUTTING THE
JERSEY SWAPS.
LIKE A RUMOR CAME OUT TODAY THAT
HE WAS RUMORED TO LIKE WHAT
MIAMI HAD GOING ON.
HE WANTED TO PLAY THERE.
BUT NO.
HE'S ENDING UP IN CLEVELAND.
AN INSANE MOVE.
I THINK IT IS SUP EXCITING.
THERE WAS THE WHOLE KEVIN DURANT
MOVE.
KYRIE IRVING DIDN'T GETMOVED.
SO DONOVAN MITCHELL WASHE LAST
DOMINO TO FALL OR POTENTILY
THE ONLY DOMINO TO FALL IN THE
OFFSEASON SO I'M SUPER EXCITED.
EXCITED TO BE TALKING ABOUT IT
WITH YOU.
WE'VE GOT PEOPLE SAYING THE CAVS
ARE WINNING THE EAST.
THE CAVS ARE LOOKING REALLY
GOOD.
I'M REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THEIR
FUTURE.
OF COURSE, THE ULITY YOU'D
JAZZ HEADING INTO THE REBUILD
AFTER THE PAIRING DIDN'T WORK
OUT THE WAY THEY HOPED IT WOULD.
NOTHING INSANE.
AND THEY ARE COMPLETELY HAVING A
FAIR SALE RIGHT NOW.
PAT BEV GOT TRADED TO THE LOS
ANGES LAKERS.
GOBERT, OF COURSE, WEEKS BEFORE
TO THEIMBERWOLVES WHERE THEY
GOT A BILLION DRAFT PICKS.
NOW EVEN MORE DRA PICKS COMING
FROMHISAST TRADE.
JUST A LOT OF STUFF GOING DOWN
OVER THERERE IN UTAH.
I'M REALLY EXCITED THOUGH.
OF COURSE, AS AN NBA FAN.
ONE OF THEOST EXCITING PARTS
ON THE ROSTER MOVEMENT.
A TEAM LIKE THE CAVALIERS MAKING
THIS HUGE MOVE AFTER YEARS OF IT
BEING THE LeBRON JAMES SHOW.
THEY HAD NOT WON MUCH AT ALL
WITHOUT LeBRON.
NOW THEY'RE HAVING AN IDENTITY
OF THEIR OWN WHICH IS REALLY
EXEXCITING.
IT WILL BE SUPER, SUPER FUN.
I'M EXCITED TO SEE WHAT THEY DO.
THE JAZZ HEADING INTO THIS WHOLE
REBUILD ERA.
MONG ON F FROROM DONOVAN MITCHE
WHO WAS SUCH A BIG PIECE OF
THEIR IDENTITY FOR SO LONG, RUD
GOBERT.
HERE WE ARE.
A NEW ERA FOR BOTH THESE TEAMS
AND THERE IS A LOT TO TALK ABOUT
ANGO INTO WITH THESE TRADES,
OF COUR.
WE SAW COLLIN SEXTON WAS
INVOLVED, DERREK GARLAND NO
LONGER BEING IN THAT BACK COURT.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR THEM I
TERMS OF THE REST OF THELAYERS
ON THEIR ROSTER?
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A LOT OF
REALLY GOOD PLAYERS O ON THAT
ROSTER.
WE'VE G GOT THE CHRIS HAYNES TWT
WITH T FULL PACKAGE.
WE'VE GOT CLEVELAND SENDING
LAURI MARKKANEN, OCHAI AGBAJI.
2027, 2029, PLUS TWORAFT PICK
SWAPS TO THE UTAH JAZZ FOR DON
IRAN MITCHELL IN THE BACK COUR
ONE OF THE BEST BACK COURTS IN
THE LEAGUE.
THERE ARE VERY FEW BACK COURTS
THAT YOU CANAKE AN ARGUMENT
FOR THAT IS BETTER THAN THE TWO
OF THOSE GUYS.
WHEN WE LOOK AT TH FULL ROSTER,
IT IS ABSOLUTELY INSANE.
WE'VE GOT A TWEET PULLED UP
HERE.
DARIUS GARLAND, EVAN MOBLEY,
KEVIN LOVE, ISAAC, RICKY RUBIO,
DEAN WADE.
JUST A RIDICULOUS ROSTER.
THIS IS SUCH A GOOD TEAM
AND PROBAY THE MOST EXCITING
PART ABOUT IT IS, THEY'RE STILL
SUPER YOUNG.
THIS WAS A TRADE THAT YOU KNOW,
THERE ARE A LOT OF RUMORS ABOUT
HIM GOING TO THE K KNICKS
POTENTIALLY.
I DIDN'T LOVE THAT PERSONALLY
BECAUSE I THOUGHT, HIM GOING TO
THE KNICKS WOULD HAVE BEEN FUN.
YOU'VE GOT BRUNSON IN THE MIX.
R.J. BARRETTTT IS YOUNG.
SO IS MCHELL ROBINS.
THEY DIDN'T REALLY HAVE THE
YOUNG, LIKE A GIVE LIKE EVAN
MOBLEY WHO COULD BECOMOME A SUP
STAR DOWN THE LINE OR DARIUS
GARLAND WHO IS LIKE THAT BONA
FIDE ALL-STAR.
IT MAKES SENSE TO TRADE FOR
MITCHELL.
YOU ADD ON TO ANOTHER YOUNG STAR
TO WHAT IS ALREADY A YOUNG CORE
AND A TEAM THAT CAN COMPETE FOR
A REALLY LONG TIME.
THIS TRADE COMPLETELY BROKE
TWITTER, AS YOU CAN SEE.
THIS TWEET OF MINE.
IT CPLETELY BROKE THE ENTIRE
APP.
LIKE IT WAS RIDICULOUS.
THERE REALLY WASN'T LIKE, YOU
COULDN'T REFRESH TWEETS.
YOU COULDN'T FIGURE ANYTHING
OUT.
IT WAS JUST RIDICULOUS.
I'VE GOT SOME PEOPLE IN THE CHAT
HERE.
WE'VE GOT THIS PERSON WHO SAYS I
WOULD HAVE BET MY HOUSE THE CAVS
WOULD WIN THE EAST.
MAYBE SAVE IT ON THE HOUSE A
LITTLE BIT.
I THINK MITCHELL IS OVERRATED
BUT A GREATIT WITH THE TEAM.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THE SHORT
COMINGS AND THE CONCERNS WITH
THE CAVALIERS.
IT IS A GREAT FIT WITH THE TEAM.
POINTS ABOUT DARIUS GARLAND
TWEETING OUT, ABOUT THE TWO OF
THEM TWEETING UP TOGETHER.
A.G. SAYS THEY ARE NOTETTER
THAN THE HEAT, BUCKS, SIXERS OR
NETS.
THE CELTICS ARE ALSO REALLY GOOD
WHICH SHOWS HOW STACKED THEY
ARE.
BUT THE CAVALIERS HAVE, WHILE
DONAVAN MITCHELL MAKES THEM
COMPETE NOW.
SOMETHING REALLY EXCITING ABOUT
THIS MOVE.
SURE.
MAYBE THEY DON'T END UP WINNING
THE EAST THIS YEAR BUT THEY'RE A
TEAM WITH SO MUCH YOUNG TALENT.
DARIUS GARLAND, I STILL BELIEVE,
23EARS OLD AT THIS POINT.
22.
EVAN MOBLEY IS HEADING INTO HIS
SECOND SEASON.
JUST THE ALL-STAR CALIBER LEVEL.
IT IS A REALLY YOUNG TEAM IN
GENENERAL.
SO IT'S NOT LIKE THEY ADDED THIS
PIE IN THERE.
HOPING THAT HE'S THE GUY THAT
WILL PUSH THEM OVER THE TOP RATE
NOW.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT COULD BE A
FEW YEARS IN THE MAKING.
WE'VE ALSO GOT THEM SAYING THE
CAVS GAVE UP TOO MUCH.
YES, THE PICKS ARE THE HUGE
THING.
AND WE'VE SEEN THIS MASSIVE RISE
IN PICKS BEING TRADEDED EVER SIE
THE THUNDER-CLIPPERS TRADE WHERE
KAWHI LEONARD AND PAUL GEORGE
WENT WITH THE TRADEDE WITH THE
THUNDER WHICH GOT THEM KAWHI
LEONARD SO THEY GAVE UP A
MILLION DRAFT PICKS.
AND DRAFT PICKS HAVE BEEN FLYING
OFF THE SHELVES.
WE SAW A RIDICULOUS NUMBER OF
PICKS TRADED.
SO THERE WAS A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY TO TRADE DRAFT PICKS
AND STUFF.
BUT IN TERMS WHAT THEY GAVE .
IF WE GO BACK TO THE CHRIS
HAYNES TWEET HERE.
COLLIN SEXTON WASN'T ON THEIR
TEAM OUTSIDE OF LIKE 11 GAMES.
HE DIDN'T EVEN PLAY.
HE REALLY WASN'T IN THEIR PLANS
ANYMORE.
AGBAJI IS A GOOD PLAYER BUT HE
WA'T THIS.
HE WOULD HAVE BROUGHT SOME D
PLAY BUT HE WASN'T ON THAT
SEASON THAT WE SAW LAST YEAR.
SO I DON'T THINK THAT IS A
MASSIVE LOSS FOR THEM
NECESSARILY.
LAURI MARKKANEN WAS THERE LAST
YEAR AND HE WAS INTEGRAL TO
THEIR SUCCESSFUL BUT I THINK
DONOVAN MITCHELL HE'S A CLEAR
UPGRADE IN TERMS OF STAR PLAYER
UPGRADE OVER LAURI MARKKANEN
WILL WE'LL HAVE TO IF I GO IT
OUT.
THEY DID GIVE UP A LOT BUT I
FEEL LIKE IT IS AN INCREDIBLE
TRADE FOR THEM.
I THINK IT DOE A LOT FOR THIS
TEAM AND BENEFITS THEM L LIKE WE
SAW HEAR.
THEY ARE PRETTY EXCITED TO PLAY
TOGETHER.
WE GO BACK AND LOOK AT THEIR
ROSTER.
THEY HAVE GARLAND, MITCHELL IN
THE BACK COURT.
THEY HAVE THE PLAYER THAT THEY
ADDED IN THE TRADE DEADLILINE.
HE WAS PRETTY SOLID OVER THE
COURSEF L LAST SEASON AND I
EXPECTCT HAVG A FULL OFF-SEASON,
HAVING TIME TO MULL TOGETHER.
YOU HAVE EVAN MOBLEY WHO I'VE
SAID A MILLION TIME.
I'M A HUGE MOBLEY GUY.
I THINK HE HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
BE A SUE THAPER GUY DOWN THELEA.
AN ALL DEFENSIVE PLAYER.
HE CAN STRETCH THE FLOOR.
HE CAN HANDLE THE BALL.
HE DOES EVERYTYTHING.
AND THE FACT THAT NOW HE HAS NOT
JUST GARLANDHO WAS A
PHENOMENAL PLAY MAKER, BUT
DONOVAN MITCHELL WHO IS A PLAY
MAKER AND PUT HIM IN SPOTS TO
SUCCEED.
I THINK IT WILL BE REALLY COOL
FOR HIS GAME.
JAROD ALLEN, ISAAC, THEY'VE GOT
DEPTH TO KEVIN LOVE IS A GIVE
THAT WAS IN THE SIXTH MAN OTHE
YEAR CONVERSATIONS.
PRIOR TO GETTING HURT, HE HAD
LIKE EIGHT THREES IN MADISON
SQUARE GARDEN WHICH WAS
RIDICULOUS.
HE WAS REALLY, REALLY FUN.
THEY HAVE A BUT NOT OF GUYS THAT
COULD MAKE SOME UPGRADES HERE
AND THERE.
I LOVE THIS ROSTER.
FOR ME, THIS IS LIKE AN A PLUS.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE TRADE FOR
THE CAVALIERS.
I REALLY CANNOT TALK MUCH,
ENOUGH ABOUT HOW MUCH I LIKE IT.
WE'VE GOT T-MAX SAYING THIS WAS
THE BEST BY THE CALF.
I AGREE.
WE'VE GOT ADRIA SAYING THE CAVS
ARE NOT MAKING THE PLAYOFFS.
I DISAGREE
IF YOU REMEMBER, THEY WERE A
TEAM THAT W WAS LIKE TOWARD THE
TOP OF THE EAST BEFORE THEY HAD
A BUNCH OF INJURIES.
JARRETT ALLEN MISSED SOME TIME
TOO.
THEY HAD SO MUCH GREAT PLAY LAST
SEASON.
BUT NOW, YOU KNOW, THEY'VE GOT
ANOTHER YEAR TO GROW AND THEY'VE
ADDED DONOVAN MITCHELL.
I WOULD BE SHOCKED IF THEY
DIDN'T MAKE THE PLAYOFF.
THOMAS SAYS KNICKS BLEW IT
AGAIN.
CHALK IT UP FOR THEM.
I THINK IT IS ALREADY THAT THEY
DIDN'T GET DONOVAN MITCHELL.
THEY JUST LOCKED UP R.J. BARRETT
LONGNG MATERIAL.
TO ME, IT FELT LIKE THIS MIGHT
BE CAPPING THEM OUT A BIT.
HELL, WOULD HAVE PUT THEM IN
THAT MIDDLE GROUND WHERE THEY'RE
NOT NECESSARILY A CONTENDER.
THEY'RE NOT A GREAT PLAYOFF TEAM
BUT THEY'RE PRETTY SOLID.
THIS GIVES THEM MORE OPPORTUNITY
IN WHAT IS A LOADED EASTERN
CONFERENCE.
IT THEY'LL BE A TEAM THAT ENDS
UP AT THE EDGE OF THE LOTTERY.
THE PLAYING AREA.
AND IT THEY CAN BE REALLY GOOD.
YOU KNOW MOVING O IN TERMS OF
THEIR FUTURE.
WE'VE GOT VICTOROR,E'VE GOT
ANOTHER GREAT PROSPECT, TOO.
ANOTHER THING GOING ON REALLY
GOOD.
LET SEE WHAT ELSE WE'VEOT IN
THE CHAT.
THIS WILL BE SCARY.
I SEE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE DEFENSE.
GARLAND AND MITCHELL, NEITHER
ARE GREAT DEFENDERS.
THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE MOBLEY
AND ALLEN REALLY ELEVATES THIS
TEAM A LOT.
HE IS A GUY THAT COULD BE ALL
DEFENSIVE AS SOON AS NEXT YEAR.
YOU'VE GOT JAROD ALLEN.
THEY'VE GOT GUYS THAT CAN SWITCH
AND MOVE AROUND DEPENDING ON
WHAT THEY NEED.
HAVING THOSE TWO GUYS, MOBLEY
AND ALLEN, ELIMINATES A LOT OF
MY CONCERNS ERE.
WE'VE GOT, WE, WHO SAY THE CAVS
WILL BE A FOUR SEEEED AT LEAST.
IT IS REALLY EXCITING.
IT RIGHT NOW, THE TOP TEAM IN
THE EAST ARE LIKE THE CELTICS.
WE'VE TO THE THE SIXERS.
AND WE'VE GOT THE MILWAUKEE
BUCKS.
THE MIAMI HEAT ARE.
IN CONVERSATION, TOO.
BUT I THINK LOSING PJ TUCKER
HURT THEM A GOOD BIT.
WE'LL SEE IF TY MAKE ANY MORE
MOVES TO FILL THAT POWER
FORWARD.
I THINK THEY'RE RIGHT THERE IN
THAT MIX WITH THE HEAT AND THE
NETS TO FILL THAT FOUR O FIVE
SPOT.
WE'LL HAVE TO SEE HOW THEY PLAY
TOGETHER.
WE'VE GOT NAPPY SAYIN YOU HAD
THE CAVS GOT BETTER BUT THEY'RE
STILL THE SAME.
I COMPLETELY DISAGREE.
MITCHELL GIVES THEM A WHOLE
DYNAMIC AND A GUY WHO CAN HANDLE
THE BALL AND CATE SHOTS.
HE WAS FORCED TO CREATE A LOT
MORE AND IT KIND OF MADE THEM
ONE DIMENSIONALLY.
A.J. SAYS IT IS AN EASY LOCK FOR
THE PLAYOFFS NOW.
I AGREE.
WE HAVE A COUPLE PEOPLE TALKING
ABOUT THE UTAH JAZZ.
HE SAYS YEAH, REST IN PEACE TO
THIS ERA.
AND SLEEVE SAYING THE JAZZ WON
THIS TRADE.
LET'S GET INTO THE UTAH JAZZ
TO KIND OF GIVE THEM, LET'SO
OVER WHAT THEY'LL LOOK LIKE NOW.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE UTAH JAZZ
AND WHAT THEY'VE BUILT U
THROUGH THIS GERT AND DONOVAN
MITCHELL TRADE.
THEY GOTMARKKANEN, AGBAJI AND
SEXTON.
I THINK THIS IS GOOD IN TERMS OF
THE BUILD.
I GIVE IT A B PLUS.
COULD THEY GET A GRIMES OR R.J.
BARRETT?
WHILE THEY DIDN'T GET ONE OF
THEM.
HE AVERAGED 24 POINTS A GAME.
OF COURSE, IT IS A BIT OF A
CONCERN.
EAT A WILL SOID PIECE THEY CAN
EITHER BUILDLD AUND OR GO TOWARD
THE FUTURE AND MAYBE THEY END UP
TRADING HIM DOWN THE LINE WHICH
IS THE BIG THING WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT WITH THE JAZZ.
IF WE LOOK HERE AT THIS TWEET,
AT THE TIME OF THI TWEET,
HERE'S WHAT UTAH GOT.
MALIK BEASLEY, THT, STANLEY
JOHNSON, WKER KESS HER, VANNER
BUILT, 2023 FIRST ROUND PICK.
TWO SWAMS IN 2026.
TWO FIRST ROUND PICKS.
THE FIRST ROUND PICK.
JORDAN CLARKSON.GOT ASSET LIKE
THEY'VE STILL GOT SO MANY GUYS
THEY CAN TRADE.
THERE ARE SO MANY GUYS THEY
COULD TRADE TO GET MORE ASSETS.
IF WE LOOK AT STAT NEWS, I'M A
THUNDER FAN IF YOU DIDN'T KNOW.
I KNOW A LOT ABOUT DRAFT PICKS.
WE TK ABOUT HOW MANY DRAFT
PICKS THEY HAVE IN THE NEXT FEW
YEARS.
THEY ARE NOW TIED IN TERMS THE
NEXT SEVEN DRAFTS IN DRAFT
PICKS.
THEY'VE BUILT IT UP AND PASS IT.
ONCE ITHAPPENS,S, ONCE THE TRAD
HAPPENS, THERERE AREO MANY MORE
MOVES TO STILL HAPPEN TO WORK
TOWARD THIS REBUILD.
THIS ISN'T THE FIRST 11.
THERE'S SO MUCH MORE THAT COULD
HAPPEN.
AND NOW I THINK IT MADE A LOT OF
SENSE TO GET DONOVANITCHELL
OUT OF THE TEAM BECAUSE HIM
BEING THIS IS ONLY GOING TO
TOGETHER MAKE YOU A BIT BETTER.
HE WON'T STAY LONG TERM.
IT MAKES SENSE TO DEAL HIM FOR
RIGHT NOW AND JUST MOVE ON TO
THE NEW ERA.
WHICH THEAZZ DESERVE A TUNNEL
OF CREDIT FOR.
WE HAVE ALL SAYING NOBODY IS
PASSING THE BALL.
I DON'T THINK CLARKSON WILL BE
THERE VERY LONG.
WE HAVE HUNT STAYING JAZZ MADE
THE RIGHT CHOICE.
I AGREE.
THEY HAD TO HAVE MOO ON.
GOBERT AND MITCHELL.
THEY GAVE THEM THE RUN.
THEY MADE A COUPLE DECENT RUNS.
THEY LOOKED SOLID AND IT DIDN'T
END UP BEING ENOUGH TO MAKE IT
OVER THE HUMP.
THEY SAI OKAY.
THIS ERA OVER.
WE'RE GOING TO CAPITALE NOW.
THEY FALL OFF A LITTLE BIT AND
THE TRADE VALUE GOES DOWN.
THEY TRADE THEM AT THEIR PEAK
TRADE VALUE AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT IS REALLY HARD TO DO.
AL LOT OF TEAM WILL STICK WITH A
TEAM WAY TOO LONG AND YOU DON'T
PET THE ASSETS.
HUNTER SAYS HE WAS A DIVA.
GLAD HE'S GONE.
IF YOU'RE THE JAZZ FAN, YOU'RE
THE FIRST JAZZ FAN I'VE SEEN SAY
THAT.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S A
SENTIMENT ACROSS THE JAZZ FAN
BASE.
AS A THUNDER FAN, IF I SAW SHEA
GET TRADED, IT WOULD BE A
RELEVANT HEART BREAKER.
I KNOW IT SUCKS TO SEE YOUR TEAM
GOING INTO A REBUD.
WATCHING WAS A HEART BREAKER BUT
IT IS THE RIGHT MOVE THAT YOU
HAVE TO M MAKE.
KEVIN SAYS THE JAZZ ROND TWO
TEAMS BLIND IN THE OFF-SEASON.
THEY GOT A TON OF PICKS.
IT WAS RIDICULOUS THE AMOUNT OF
ASSETS THAT THEY ADDED THROUGH
THIS WHOLE THING.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU MEAN RIGHT
NOW OR FOR THE FUTURE
I'M GOING TO ASSUME YOU MEAN FOR
THE FUTURE.
THEY'VE GOT SEXTON, JAROD
VANDERBILT.
I'M EXCITED TO SEE WHAT
HORTON-TUCKER DOES.
A LOT MORE PRESSURE-FILLED ROLE.
HE DOESN'T HAVE TO IMMEDIATELY
CONTINUE.
I THINK WALKER KESSLER, JUST THE
FIRST ROUND PICK.
BEASLEY IS STILL PRETTY YOUNG
BUT I'M SURE THEY'LL FLIP HIM.
THEAZZ WILL BE A REALLY
INTERESTING TEAM TO KEEP UP
WITH.
THERE'S A TON OF WAYS THEY CAN
GO WITH THIS REBUILD.
AND I'M EXCITED TO SEE HOW THEY
DECIDE TO GO.
DO THEY HOLD ON TO THEIR PIECES
LIKE A COUPLE OF YOUNG GUYS DO?
DO THEY WAIT UNTIL THE DAET
LANE?
WHO IS THE LEADING SCORER NEXT
SEASON?
IT WILL L BE COLLIN SEXTON I WOD
IMAGINE.
IT WOULD BE KIND OF FUN TO SEE
HIM GO OUT THERE AND PUT UP 30
POINTS PER GAME.
TRADE THE REST OF THE GUYS.
LET HIM HOOP AND SEE WHAT HE
PUTS TOGETHER.
JUST MAKE THINGS HAPPEN.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS WITH HIM.
THERE ARE NOT MY SCORERS THAN
HIM ON THE TEAM.
YOU HAVE LIKE WE TALKED ABOUT,
JORDAN CLARKSON.
I THINK HE'LL END UP GETTING
MOVED A AS A CONTENDER.
I THINK HE'S A SUPER VALUABLE
PIECE.
SO WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THE JAZZ.
THERE WERE OTHER TEAMS IN THE
CONVERSATION WITH THE JAZZ.
OTHER TRADE PACKAGES OUT THERE.
THE WIZARDS AND HORNETS WERE TWO
TEAM THAT ARE WERE RUMORED.
IT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE A TON OF
ASSETS.
AND IT D DIDN'TEALLY MAKE SENSE
TO ME.
SOMEWHERE TO THE KNICKS
SITUATION WHERE I DIDN'T REALLY
FEEL LIKE HE WOULD HAVE ELEVATED
NUMBER OFF THOSE TEAMS ENOUGH.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE NEW YORK
KNICKS.
I KNOW THERE ARE A LOT OF KNICKS
FANS THAT ARE REALLY SAD ABOUT
THIS.
I THINK THIS IS IS FINE FOR THE
KNICKS.
I THINK THEY'RE A TEAM STILL IN
THAT MIDDLE GROUND.
I FEEL LIKE THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
MORE PIECES IN THE DRAFT.
THEY'LL BE RIGHT THERE IN THAT
CUSP.
MAYBE THEY MAKE A PLAYOFF RUN
T I THINK THEY'LL BE IN THE
PLAY INTO THE LOTTERY AND THAT
GIVES THEM A CHANCE TO GO GET A
GREAT DRAFT PICK.
SOMETHING ELSE THAT HELPS WITH
THE JAZZ.
WHY THEY DECIDED TO GO ALL OUT
AND GIVE EVERYTHING UP THIS
YEAR.
THIS DRAFT CLASS IS COMPLETELY
STACKED.
SO THE JAZZ GOING ALL IN MADE
SENSE.
WITH THE NEW YORK KNICKS NOW,
THEY'RE IN THE SAME SPOT.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO GIVE UP A
MILLION DRAFT PICKS.
THERE WERE RUMORS THAT THEY
WOULD GETETET THEM FOUR FUTURE D
PICKS.
QUENTON GRIMES, THEY WANTED ALL
THEIEIR PIECES
AND THAT TO ME FELT LIKE IT
WOULD BE AIDICULOUS AMOUNT.
I'M GOING TO GIVE THEM A B.
I THINK THAT THEY STUCK TO THEIR
GUNS AND DIDN'T GIVE UP WAY MORE
THAN THEY WANTED TO GIVE UP.
THEY WERE LIKE, THIS IS OUR
OFFER.
THEY DIDN'T GIVE UP THEIR A
S
ASSE.
AS A KNICKS FAN, HE SAYS LIFE IS
PRETTY HARD RIGHT NOW.
YEAH.
YOU HAVE JALEN BRUNSON.
YOU JU LOCKED UP LONG TERM, A
YOUNG PIECE.
A REALLY EXCITING PLAYER.
IT HE'S IN FOR A REALLY GOOD
SEASON.
EXCITED TO SEE WHAT HE CAN DO.
QUENTON GRIMESES, TOO, I THINK
AN INCREDIBLE YOUNG PIECE.
HE LOOKED WAY TOO GOOD FOR THE
SUMMER LEAGUE.
SO I THINK THE KNICKS WILL BE
PERFECTLY FINE.
HE SAYS, KNICKS FANS ALREADY
DOWN BAD THOUGHGH.
FUN FACT, I'M LIVE STREAMI
FROM NEW YORK SO MAYBE LATER
I'LL GO OUTSIDE AND SEE WHAT
KNICKS FANS ARE FEELING ABOUT
THIS WHOLE THIN
WE'LL SEE.
WE'LL SEE WHEN THE CAVALIERS
COME TO TOWN.
WE'VE GOT THE UNDERDOGS, OR,
THAT'S A TOUGH COMPARISON IF YOU
MEAN LIKE, HOW DID THEY, ARE
THEY TRYING TO BUILD A BETTER
TETEAM?
STUFF LIKE THAT?
WE'VE GOT A REPORT THAT I'LL
PULL UP REAL QUICK TO GO OVER
ABOUT THIS.
GO OVER WITH THE TRADE,
OBVIOUSLY, WE'VE GOT RATE THIS
BACK COURT.
GARLAND AND DONOVAN MITCHELL.
I DON'T KNOW.
IT IS A REALLY GOOD BACK COURT.
THERE AREN'T A LOT OF BACK
COURTS THAT COME TO MIND THAT
CAN COMPETE WITH THIS BACK
COURT.
WE'VE GOT SOME OF THE, STEFA
CLAY WAS ONE OF THE BETTER ONES.
JAMES HARDEN, WE'VE GOT DEJOUNTE
MURRAY.
SOME REALLY GOOD BACK COURTS.
BUT GARLAND, REALLY GOOD
ALL-STARS.
I THINK DARIUS GARLAND COULD GET
THERE AT SOMOME POINT.
NOT TOO FAR AWAY.
HE WAS RIDICULOUS LAST SEASON.
SO THEY'RE REALLYGOOD.
LIKE OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD.
THERE WEREERY FEW BACK COURTS
AT ALL THAT I THINK ARE BETTER
THAN THIS BACK COURT.
THEY MIGHT BEHE BEST ONES.
THE CONCERN ABOUT THE DEFENSE, I
THINK POEBLY AND ALLEN COVER
THAT UP.
THEY'VE GOT CORA, A.J. HAMILTON
SAYING I KNOW HE'S EXCITED TO GO
FROM UTAH TO OF ALL PLACES,
CLEVELAND.
I'M SURE THEY CLEARED IT WITH
HIM.
THERE IS NO WAY THEY CLEARED IT.
EARLIER, TALKING ABOUT THE
KNICKS BEATING THE BROWNS.
THERE IS BEEN STRAIGHGHT DVD
MOVIES THAT HAD MORE SUCCESS
THAN THE KNICKS.
THAT'S THE THING.
THIS ISN'T JUST FOR NOW.
IT'S NOT JUST THE TRADE FOR YOU
NO.
PART OF WHY I LOVE IT SO MUCH IS
BEBECAUSE IT HELPS THEM IN THE
FUTURE, TOO.
MITCHELL IS LOCKED UP FOR A FEW
SCENES.
JARRETT ALLEN, MOBLEY IS JUST
ENTERING HIS SECOND SEASON.
SAY YOU HAD A CONTENDING TEAM
TRADED FOR KEVIN DURANT, FOR
EXAMPLE.
NO NOW IT'S LIKE, HE'S 34 YEARS
OLD.
YOU HAVE TO WIN ITT NOW.
HE IS REALLY YOUNG.
HE HASN'T EVEN HIT HIS PRIME
YET.
SO YOU'VE GOT HIM, GARLAND,
MOBLEY, ALLEN.
AN SINGLE ONE OF THEM IS EVAN
MOBLEY WHO COULD BE THE BEST ONE
ON THAT TEAM.
PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT THE
CLEVELAND REUNION.
IF HE CAME BACK NOW, THAT WOULD
BE EVEN MORE INSANE.
HE DID SIGN THAT EXTENSION WITH
THE LAKERS SO PROBABLY NOT.
SOMETHING TO THINK ABOUT A
LITTLE BIT THERE.
I LOVE IT FOR THE CAVS.
IT THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE JOB
PUTTING TOGETHER A TEAM T THAT C
COMPETE.
FOR NOT JUST NOW BUT THE LONG
TERM.
AND FOR THE JAZZ, I THI IT IS
A WIN FOR THEM, TOO.
THEY TRADED DONAVAN MITCHELL.
WHILE THE VALUES WERE STILL
HIGH.
EY HAVE 15 FIRST ROUND PICKS
IN THE NEXT SET OF DRAFTS.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE GREAT.
I THINK THAT, I REALLY THINK
THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO REALLY
LOOK FORWARD TOWARD THEIR FUTURE
RIGHT NOW.
FORWARD TO.Y HAVE A TON TO LOOK
I PROMISE THINGS WILL BE OKAY.
THE JAZZ WILL MAKE IT BACK.
IF YOU GET SCOOT HENDERSONON IN
THIS UPCOMING DRAFT, YOU WILL BE
FINE.
SOME TINY MEN IN THAT BACK
COURT.
I THINK IT WILL BE GOOD.
THEY'V GOT TWO SEVEN FOOTERS IN
THE FRONT COURT TO EVEN THAT
OUT.
THE CAVS HAD LAURI MARKKANEN
LAST AREA.
THE CAVS HAVE NEVER BEEN SOUP
EVERY CONVENTIONAL IN TERMS OF
PLAYER SIDE.
SO OVERALL, IT THIS WAS A GREAT
JOB BY BOTH SIDES.
I THINK THIS IS A TRADE THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE WILL LOOK A DOWN
THE LINE AND TAL ABOUT HOW
INSANE IT WAS.
IT CAN REALLY CRASH MY APP.
DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU ALL.
I THOUGHT HE WOULD END UP AS A
KNICK.
INSTEAD, HENDS UP AS A
CLEVELAND CAVALIER.
IF I H TO GIVE SOMEWHERE WHERE
I THOUGHT THE CAVS WOULD BE THIS
UPCOMING SEASON, I THINK THEY
COULD END UP AS A FIVE SEED.
I THINK THEY'RE ABLE TO, THEY'RE
ABLE TO MAKE THAT RUN.
HAVE YOUNG TALENT GROW,
POTENTIALLY PASS THESE OLDER
TEAM IN THE EASTERN CONFERENCE.
YEAH.
SO I THINK THAT THEY'VE DONE A
GREAT JOB.
I'M EXCITED.
WE HEAD OVER TO, SEE, WE'VE GOT,
I BELIEVE WE HAVE A PRETTY CLEAN
JERSEY SWAM COMING UP.
WHICH IS WEIRD.
I CAN'T REALLY IMAGINE DONOVAN
MITCHELL IN A CAVS JERSEY YET.
HERE IT IS.
WE'VE G MOBLEY, MITCHELL,
GARLD, LET ME KNOW HOW IT
LOOKS.
I THINK IT LOOKS PRETTY GOOD.
KIND OF NATURAL.
THE FACT THAT HE ISN'T EVEN IN
THIS JERSEY SPOT SHOWS HOW
TALENTED THEY ARE.
THEY HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO BE
RIDICULOUS.
IT WILL BE INSANE.
WE'VE GOT CHIRPY SAYING HAVING
TO L LIV IN UTAH NOW.
THE JAZZ WILL BE BACK.
WE'VE GOT L WILL SING IT.
IN A SEVEN-GAME SERIES, I MEAN,
IT TEAMS WON'T WANT TO PLAY
THEM.
THEY WERE REALLY GOOD LAST AREA
PRAYER TO THIS WHOLE SITUATION.
PRIOR TO INJURIES, THE CAVS ARE
ONE OF THE BETTER TEAM IN THE
EASTERN CONFERENENCE.
IF I REMEMBER CORRECTLY, THEY
WERE TOWARD THE TOP FOR A GOOD
BIT THIS SEAS.
THEY WERE DOING AN INCREDIBLE
JOB.
AND NOW THEY ADD DONOVAN
MITCHELL WHO CAN PLAY MAKE,
CREATE SHOTS FOR OOFRLS MOBLEY
CAN TAKE A JUMP.
GARLAND CAN KEEP GETTING BETTER.
GERALD ALLEN, OFF THEBENCH.
HE WAS REALLY INCREDLE.
IF RICKY RUBIO CAN COME BACK TO
ANYTHING LIKE THE FORM HE WAS
AT.
IT'S A REALLY GOOD TEAM.
FRED SAYS, THINK THEY CAN BEAT
THE VOLCANOES IN A SEVEN-GAME
SERIES?
I THINK THEY GO.
IT DEPEND ON HEALTH.
ALONZO BALL IF HE'S BACK.
IF BOTH TEAMS ARE HEALTH THAT
WOULD BE ONE HELL OF A SERIES.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE HOW THAT
GOES.
GARLAND, ALONZO BALL.
NOW I REALLY WANT TO SEE THIS
SERIES.
THANK YOU FOR PUTTING THAT IN MY
MIND.
PLAYOFF MATCH UPS, GARLAND AND
MITCHELL GOING AGAINST HARDING.
I'M REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
TEAM.
HE SAYS HE LOOKS CRAZY IN THAT
JERSEY.
HE BE THIS IN NEW YORK.
THIS HURTS.
IT LOOKS REALLY NATURAL.
I'M SURPRISED.
I T THOUGHT IT WOULD TAKE A LOT
LONGER FOR ME TO GET USED TO
THIS BUT IT LOOKS REALLY
NATURAL.
I REALLY DIDN'T EXPECT IT TO GO
THAT KIND OF CRAZY.
EVAN THINK SAYS, I'M BE GNG TO
LIE.
COMPLETELY RIGHT, IT.
IT IS A REALLY FUN TRIO.
BIG FOUR THAT THEY'VE GOT WITH
JARRETT ALLEN.
A REALLY FUN YOUNG TEAM.
I THINK THAT IT HAS TO BE
EXCITING.
IF YOU'RE A CAVS FAN OUT THERE,
LIKE VERY EXCITED FOR YOU.
IT IT WOULD BE REALLY GOOD.
THE JERSEYS ARE HIDEOUS BUT
THAT'S A FUN SQUAD.
I DON'T THINK SO.
I LIKE THE CAVS JERSEYS.
IF HE WITH WANT TO TALK WITH
HORRIBLE JERSEYS A WE'RE
TALKING GOING A EMAT A W TALKED
ABOUT, WE CAN GO BACK TO THE
UTAH JAZZ JERSEYS.
I'LL SPARE YOU FROM HAVING TO
LOOK A THOSE.
WE'LL WRAP IT UP WITH THAT.
I APPRECIATE YOU ALL TUNING .
GO TO COHEN ON TWITTER THERE.
PODCAST CALLED THE THUNDER TWO.
YOU KNOW, I TALK ABOUT
BASKETBALL SOMETIMES.
REALLY EXCITED TO GET THEHE CHAE
TO TALK WH YOU ALL.
I APPRECIATE YOU TUNING IN.
A LOT OF FUN.
THIS WILL TRADE IS RIDICULOUS.
KEEP YOUR FINGERS CROSSEDHA